can bring you some breaking news here on
all out politics public health
england has detected samples of the kent
variant
with mutations that may help it evade
the immune system
when we get more now from our science
correspondent thomas moore
thomas uh thank you for joining us uh so
we're a lot of talk about variants but
this is basically
uh the kent variant becoming like the
south african variant is it
exactly that in effect it's it's
developed a superpower
adam that this is a mutation in the
south african variant that seems to not
only help it infect
cells but also to evade the immune
system the reason being that the spike
protein
that all the covid viruses use to to
latch onto human cells
changes shape and that means that the
antibodies don't recognize it
in quite the same way and the fact that
they have this
mutation is called e484k has now been
picked up in some samples
of the ken variant would be a twist a
worrying development
because it potentially means that people
who have had the
infection before might be reinfected
and also that it would reduce the
effectiveness of the covid vaccines not
knock them out completely certainly the
tests done so far suggests that
the vaccines would still protect against
serous infection and death
but perhaps they wouldn't stop the virus
spreading and that would mean that
people
who couldn't have the vaccine or didn't
want the vaccine that they would still
be
vulnerable to infection i have to say
it's just 11 samples out of
something like 200 000 that have been
sequenced
but the fact that it has been detected
through random
sampling suggests that there are more
out there and it's ever more reason to
try and stop this virus spreading
further to reduce the
overall infection rate because if you do
that it reduces
all viruses all variants and it also
reduces the chances
of new mutations occurring
and thomas how does this information
relate to
the current test and trace campaign
uh concentrated in certain areas to get
a handle on the south african variant
well certainly that was done because uh
it had been detected
that the 11 cases with no travel history
whatsoever had been detected
here in the uk strong suggesting that
the virus had begun to spread within
communities that's a worrying
development again for the same reason
that this 484k mutation
does uh mean that the virus would be
less sensitive
uh to the vaccines now the hope is that
because they've
detected the very early sparks they
believe of this uh this outbreak
that they can snuff it out at an early
stage through
rigorous test and trace convincing
people uh to
to isolate and we know that that's not
always successful but
it's going to need to be done in this
case somehow uh even if that's through
some financial means
that it is going to need to to just try
and stop this mutation
spreading because it is it gives the
virus such an advantage
it's likely that it would potentially
become
the dominant strain uh quite quickly